Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier
and welcome back to Prison Architect.
big problem going on here.
We got one person dead and then a bullet waiting for Wallace,
and I don't know *deep breath*
what I'm gonna be able to do to fix that!
I have a funny feeling this isn't gonna end very happy
considering a lot of that's going on in here has not been
too terribly happy.
Oh, oh good, they unlocked that finally.
I don't know how we're gonna get power
in here this is gonna be nuts.
the fire's already been put und-- oh no, the
fire is not under control, oh my goodness
oh my goodness, oh my goodness i did--  I
thought that the fire was under control.
Bring both fire engine please! Oh, there's
no room for it.
Okay, we got to get- oh the hearse oh my
god, we gotta get the hearses out of here
Okay, we need a lot more workers if this is
going to work like this.
Get in there, get in there, get in there!
Just get it done, get it done, get it done
We got stuff to do, we got things to work
on, we don't have time to wait around.
All right we got that done. Still a lot
dying but, we got to get the fires in
here so make this room, uuuh, make one of them an
infirmary - be the top one, and the bottom
one will be the morgue and I'm actually
going to separate these out, I'm going to
remove the doors and we're gonna just
gonna have -- we're just gonna have normal
doors because I don't need those,
so we're gonna put those later. Alright,
so got that.
Okay, so we're going to build floors, get
nice white tiles and all this boinkidy
boink
Okay, and then for a morgue... we need medical
beds. Boinkidy boinkidy boinkidy boinkidy boink *boink seems foreign now*
and boink!
Okay and then we need morgue slabs. Ugh, slabs...
It's a lovely way... okay, look at all the
slabs we can house! So many slabs
Oh, like looking at it reminds me of
those uh RPG horror maker games RPG
Maker horror games that I played before.
You know, the really, really fun bizarre
ones. Okay so we need electricity going
through here, running
into this room across here, and across
there, and that should be enough to get
everything covered.
All right, go go go we gotta go. Man, i do not have enough security staff.
Uh, let's get more and more guards more
guards more guards more guards guards
guards guards guards guards guards guards
guards guards guards guards
Ok, man i got all my workers working on
cleaning this up, it looks like the fires
are out at least, I think anyway, yeah the
fires under control so these guys can go
away
Not that I had him in the area
anymore... This crew is pretty much dead so
I can send them away.
Alright, so we need what happened that a-- wha-- I- I stationed police in here.
I stationed police in there. I stationed
police in there.
All right I gotta get -- oh geez yeah
he's a one-man army.
Go for it! Go for it breh! Alright, so we
need guards but not yet apparently.
Well that guy is a fighter. Whoa geez
maybe we need all these guys in here.
Ok, ok good they're all fixed up.
That's good to go. Okay, so that's good. Uh... Oh
no, we're good.
Alright, we're good. Benedict's calling . Oh boy,
here we go...
"I want my wheels now! Wallace is joining
us and if I catch sight of a tail you'll
be scraping pieces of him off the
freeway."
Oh, thank you for the lovely call always
good catching up.
"That's it! It's time to bring the
situation to an end. The team is all in
position."
"None of us are getting out of here. It's
not you they want."
"What are you talking about? I did it for
money, but he did it for political gain.
The longer the sentences the more votes
he got..."   Who the fuck you talking about?
"Mayor Heller; it was his blueprint, I just
oiled the wheels."
Oh, that's not good. "Those files with the
evidence that could destroy his career."
"You're shitting me."
Oh boy, oh this is not gonna end well.
Oh, they're too happy about that. "What
the fuck... They're coming in,
get ready. I fucking warned you!" *gunshot* Oh, Jeeze
Whoa, whoa WHOA! They shot Wallace!
Whoa
That wasn't, that wasn't Benedict that
shot Wallace, that was the cops!
Wallace... Oh, he was my guide in this.
Were they intentionally going for him, or did
they just shoot him because they were
trying to shoot
Benedict? I-I'd put my
money on they intentionally shot him.
They were TOLD to. Oh, hi Calvin Heller.
Too bad I saw that! "The facility is under
control and the rioters have been subdued.
It could easily have turned out a lot
worse."    Yeah,
much worse -_-    "We've got one hell of a
clean-up operation ahead of us.
I'd appreciate your help with that, if
you've got the time."  Well, I got nothing
better to do.
I don't know exactly if I'm going to be
the next target on your list, considering
what I know. "We don't have any building
contractors on site so, the first step
will be to hire some new workmen to get
to work repairing the place.
I always thought security here was much too lax.
These inmates have been given too much
free reign for too long.
That stops today!"  Yeah, I think it stops
because of all the dead bodies that have
piled up.
"I want you to build us a new armory, then
deploy armed guards in key positions
around the prison.
The sight of that will subdue these
prisoners and they'll think twice about
causing this much trouble again."
*Breathes, swallows* "I'm also approving the funds to provide body armor to all the guards on site, our
men need to be able to defend themselves.
We've got a few other requir-
quirements; there are a lot of
prisoners who need to be taught the
error of their ways.
Build a new solitary confinement wing."    I don't like you... I like Wallace.
I don't like Mayor Calvin Heller.   "Our
guards will take care of moving inmates *howdy*
to solitary as required.
Solitary confinement gives inmates
time to reflect on what they've done and
reminds them who's in charge around here. There's a lot to do here,
we really appreciate your help. Once you feel you've done enough and are ready to
move on,
click on the polaroid by the front gates."
Oh my goodness!
I don't know if I want to be a part of
this...
What does free fire mean?? Oh God.
Turn that off, thank you very much!
*owl noises*
That's too much! Woof, whoo, I gotta
move on because holy shit... what the hell
happened.
"Conviction"   That could mean a few things.
Oh, hello,
tattooed naked person. Oh, not-- not quite
naked.
ok
Dr. Walter Hearse: "The lack of engagement at
this facility is shocking; men deprived
of every shred of humanity."
Yeah! I agree!    "They're being shown scant
compassion or respect." Oh it's The Chief: "It's not
what these men deserve."   Who are you to say
what these men deserve, chief.
"Indeed, captain. This is no way to treat a
human being. They're deprived of every shred of
humanity.
Why should they abide by our rules? You can't expect them to respond in any way
but the utmost resentment.
We need classrooms, drug rehabilitation
programs, a workshop so they can start to
take some pride in their skills."
"You misunderstand me, Doctor, these men
aren't human.
See for yourself see for yourself."      *Demon voice* Seee for yourselfff...
"On your feet, Morgan!"      ...Morgan Freeman?
Oh, no... "You've got a visitor."    I don't want
to be a part of this- "Rehabilitation?
Might as well teach monkeys to play the banjo."
...I don't like this guy. I think i'm
supposed to no-not like him!
And I think I like this Dr. man. "What's your name son?"
"Man asked you a question."
"Henry, sir."
"Must be cold down there, Henry. Put this on."
"Lice in the bed, sir. Eating me alive. Shirt keeps out the rats - biggest one I've
ever seen."
Oh God! *Noise of disgust*   "How are you sleeping?"
"Don't sleep. Only thing I do in here is
think. Lots of time for thinking."
"What do
you think about?"
"Dying, mostly. And my
little girl."   Aaaaaw!
"She'll need you to be strong, Henry. This will be hard for her, too."
"Been behind bars every s- every day of her life. She doesn't know I exist."
*Noise of simpathy*  "It's never too late to change a life,
Henry. I'd like to come and see you again,
if I may."
"Yes, sir. Thank you, sir."     Oh, man...
"Call me Walter."
"Can we do something about those rats? This isn't the third world."
"I'll get some rat poison in there."
Well that seems- No! 'at seems like a bad thing.
The guy thinks about dying an' they're give him
rat poison or put rat poison in a cell-
Oh boy, hi Doc, how're you doin'.
"Following the recent tragedy at Alchemico
State Prison we were under immense
political scrutiny. Until a permanent
replacement is found for the CEO
position, I'd like you to take the reins.
There have been a spate of suicides of
this facility recently and it's not hard
to see why.
But we have a more immediate problem. The powers that be have decided to send us a
huge batch of new inmates. *howdy* The first will be arriving tomorrow,
and we don't have anywhere to house them. We
need you to build a brand new cell block
with enough space to handle the new
intake."
Oh boy. Alright can do! Ooh it's even
framed out!
"I've laid out the potential design for
the new cell block here. This should give
us a new- enough new cells to handle the intake
and the design includes its own shower
facility."    Handy that! A good place for people to murder each other, apparently.
"But it's up
to you if you choose to follow this
design or something totally different.
My job is to prioritise the welfare of
these men. Get that new cell block built,
and we'll talk about to achieve that."
Okay, just leave that up here. I want to
do the exact framework.
I am a hundred percent down to clown
with this.
Ok, concrete wall. Oh, let me speed this up
a little bit.
Hurry up, guys. Hurry up, please. please.
please, hurry up. please. please.
Plz. Plz. Okay, I need to put a door
on the front
there. It's gonna be the only entrance in
and out-- work faster! Please!?
I don't know, I don't know what I need to
do. "Provide cells for 40 inmates."
Ugh. 'S so sad.
So sad
Okay, so now that we got that and the doors
installed, we can make rooms here
..no we cannot. I need to make this-- whao, what
is the sound of that?
Oh! They're not done. Oh, okay.
AHA! There we go!
Okay, nooow I can do it. Boink! Okay, so now that I
got that. Beepidy-beep
I'm a simple guy; I'm gonna follow this
plan to the T, and not deviate from it
ever
Oh, woulds it be easier just to do this, and
cancel it?
Prooobably. All right, now I'm going to
build the yard and im gonna build it
right outside here, so that it's fenced
in, and they can get to it, and they WILL
be able to get to it when I build, not
all that... but I'm going to build large
jail doors on both of these; they can get
right into the yard and have all the fun
times they need.
Probablyyy.
Okay, but at least that's there, that's
good, uh,
the majority of this is here-- Oh, shit
contraband found over there!
Oh, God, he got beaten to a bloody pulp!
Oh, man, the state of this prison is not
okay. Right, now I need to hook this up to
water, and it would be pretty much good
Okay, Oooh I need to put toilets in all of
them they need to go potty.
That's right, I forgot about that.
And, apparently, I forgot to build walls here.
Boop and boop. Didn't want people going
through to anybody else's room, and now I
need to get water to all those shiii-
*noises, more noises, be imaginative, a little more, do it again, another, one more and done*
And that should be everything that we
need for this, and then everyone is going
to be A-okay --  I didn't put like TVs or book
shelves or anything because... we don't
have a kind of budget and we can't deal
with that, but I need to put some stuff
outside in the yard, so that they can all
get their *sassy* exocaise
Nice.
Plenty of weights; that's all they
get to do.
Okay! So, I think we're goooood. We got cells
for 30 peeps, right? That's gotta be 30.
Maybe I need to bunk bed these shit?
I have no idea, is that gonna be good
enough?
Can you get that in there done yet
pleaaase. Why is there no power over there...
'S there just not enough power anywhere?
What is that, anyway?
Why is there a light there? That doesn't make
any sense. That's bullshit!
"Provide a
shower facility"    I THINK this is a shower
room, isn't it??
Oh, do I need specify? Ahhh, specify. Boink!
This is a shower~!
Okay, and then these are cells~!
These are also cells~! Boink!
These are a hundred percent probably cells, these are
also maybe cells~! DONE!
...Was that not done!?
Alright, someone's gonna bunk bait! Buh-bunk bed bait.
bunk bunkterbate. Someone's gonna be
masturbating in the bunk bed, far as I
know anyway. They got cells enough for
everybody. "Enclosed, surround by walls and
doors"     What do you mean it's not enclosed??
Why is it not enclosed?? It's surrounded by
walls and doors what are you talking
about??  It's surrounded by- OOOh!
I didn't see that. Boink!
Let's fix that quickly, please. Please,
pretty please. Pretty, pretty pleaaase!
Anybody? Anybody coming and fix this
please? Anybody? Anybody at all?
Nobody? Nobody wants to fix this. Nobody?
Nobody? Nobody? There we go!
Is that gonna fix everything? What do you mean "not
enclosed: surrounded by walls and or-" it
IS enclosed! Quite obviously enclosed.
Oooh, I know what happened! Okay, I know what
happened- it was um,
Yeah, the... for some reason these were
sticking out on the ends there, I didn't
mean to do that.
Okay, so NOW we got everything.
Yes! Dr. Walter Hearst; hello how's it going?"
Oh, you're visiting the patient again.
"I was hoping to see you at one of my
sessions."
"I can't do it. I can't stay in this whole
any longer."
"Just take it a day at a time."
"I mean the whole stinking place. In here. Out there
they won't let me see my family. I messed
up, sir,  that ain't about to change."
"Henry, it's going to be okay. I'm right
behi-- side you."
"It's funny. He said the exact same thing."
"Who, Henry?
You can tell me."  Is it Wallace?
Ugh, it was Wallace,
wasn't it?
Oh, who's that? That's not Wallace.
"He looked out for me."
Uh-huh
"Ever since we were kids."
Uh-huh. Well, that don't look good.
OH! It's Benedict, it's all connected!
"Keep your shit together. Whatever happens, kid. I'm right beside you."
Oh geez, probably why this guy is being unfairly treated.
"Hands up, Motherf*ckers!"
"Grab the money, kid!"
Okay, got the money, I got the money!"
Forget the money in the car, let's just
get their mon-- uh-oh, that's not good.
That definitely dates this time. They're
definitely nineteen fifties looking shit.
Uh-oh! Well that ain't good.
"Drop your weapons now, probably
maybe. We'll probably still use lethal
force anyway!"
Oh gosh, oh geez.
"Oh shit!"
"Shoot, goddammit!"
"What the hell you waiting for? Shoot you
fucking pussy!"
They look so cool behind that car, I
guess.
Oh geeze, not cool anymore! Not cool,
one-hundred percent not cool. Ugh, this is not cool.
*Arrrrgh*
"Shit shit shit!"
"Don't shoot! Don't shoot!"
Oh man...
Man, this game gets so heavy!
I love the story, going through here though, I
love this story.
Oh! And that was a picture that was used
before! That was a picture earlier in the
game and-- oh man, now shows why he got the
shoulder injury.
"Right beside me?"
Oh geez...
"He ain't there no more."
"I'll make you an agreement; come to my
next group and i'll see if we can relax
your visitation privileges."
"you'd do that for me, sir?"
"It's not just for you, Henry." -- it's for
eeeverybody. Everybody.
Oh, something's gonna go wrong. I have a feeling.
"We've treated these men like
dirt for too long.
That ends now! The previous CEO was never
a big believer in prisoner reform, but the
way I see we need to provide these men
with some sense of hope for the future.
We need to give them the skills they
need to succeed when they're released.
Valuable trade skills; a basic education.
We should start a workout apprenticeship
scheme. Train these men with some
real-world skills, so that they have at
least have a future they can look
forward to."
I completely agree to that! I'll actually,
hundred percent agree with that because,
there's a lot of like- there's a lot of
this culture that when you put- when
people think of prisons, they think
prison is like extremely harsh
punishment, which of course should be
when you do a horrible crime, you should
be punished for it. But at the same time
they shunt him into prison, and then
just lose all hope for them, and that's
not the society that, hopefully, will come
about in the future. Because there should
be some 'reform' in terms of prison. And
lego I won't make too many grand sweeping
statements, but it should just be a basic
thing that they're still human.
Like, no matter what uh, happens. I understand
the crimes are horrendous in many cases
and each- each case is individually
treated, but in the end of the day, the
majority of them should at least be
treated like humans. Because if they
don't treat others like humans, and then
you don't treat them like humans,
how are they ever gonna realize that
there's a life outside of the life
they've chosen. But anyway! That's all I'll say,
back to the game, this is a game.
I shouldn't take this too seriously, I
should try to *deep breath* say things about that and
it's whatever and it's
okay. SO, anyway, wow, that's a lot of stuff.
"Authorized prison labor through
bureaucracy".
Okay, so, is that in heeeere? Is that a
program?
"Behavioral Therapy". That be nice.
"Pharmacological treatment, Spiritual
Guidance" Uhm, "Prison Bureaucracy".
Oh, here!
Whoa! I didn't even know this existed!
What the hell is this??
Alright! Bink! Cooool!
Wow, alrighty then.
*laughs* "The cells in your prison
require a certain amount of space to fit
legal requirements, but imagine how many
more cells you could fit in if that
wasn't the case!
Removes the minimum size requirement for
Sanders cells". Just a bed and nothing
else! They can shit on the floor. Yeh!
Yeah, okay, so we need-- wow this is a lot
of stuff! Okay, we also need education for
that!
Um, "sign inmates to work in the kitchen.
go to logistics and then prison labor".
Mmm, "kitchen safety and hygiene".
"Logistics"? Where's "Logistics"?
Okay, NOW they're showing me a bunch of stuff that
I have no idea.
Okay, let me just take this one at a time.
Uh, assign export zones near the road.
I can do that. Export zones can be done.
I'm going to assign that because I know
how to do that! That is easy.
Let's do that: export zones riiight...
here. TADA~!
Okay, so that's that. They're
gonna do their thing.
"Assign inmates to work in the workshop".
I don't know where the workshop is.
"Logistics", where the hell is "Logistics"? *LOL, Mark*
Ooooh MY God, I don't know where this is~!!
Oh shit, this is whoo, woof, woof, whoo, whoo
whoo whoo whoo whoo. WHOOwhoowhoo.
"Build a workshop" We need
to build a workshop. Okay, so we need to
build a workshop first. That's priority.
So let's do thaaat. Okay, so we neeeeed aaaaa-
-aaaa workshop! Okay, so we're gonna make this
a workshop. Babidityboombiddyboomboom *your guess is as good as mine* and I don't know what
goes IN a workshop, but I'm gonna find out!
"Assign inmates to work in the workshop".
So, i'm assuming that a workshop makes
things like, probably, the optional
produce a hundred license plates, which
would be nice, 'cause then we could get
some money from that. Can I build the
rest of that wall please? Thank you.
Okay, so now that's gonna do that and I
need to fill it up with electrical power
and all the Jazz that it needs. Badabing badaboom! Okay, so that's there,
alright, we got that; door is ready to
go, lights will come up as soon as that's
done, they got the yard over there-- that
does not have power over there... shit, they
weren't able to watch TV, because I'm an
a-hole and didn't provide the needs.
Okay, so that's there, that's good.
Okay, so now the room, the workshop... the
workshop is... What do I do in the workshop??
There we go! The workshop saw. Well, that
doesn't seem dangerous.
That's really dangerous, oh boy.
Alright, you know what? I don't know how
I feel about this, but let's do it anyway.
Alright. Boink! Let's put that right up
against-- nah let's give a little space.
Workshop. Workshop. Workshop.
Yeah, okay. Just loooad it up. Mmm... workshop
press! Boink, boink, boink, boink... I said boink!
Why isn't it boinking~!?
Okay, so we need to start "workshop safety induction" right
here, so we need to do that
"No regime time slot" --I don't know how to
do that! "Kitchen & Safety hygiene" also we
need to do that, but we need to have a
meeting room.
There probably is a meeting room around
here isn't there? Ugh, I don't know if there is~!!!
There's a visitation room over there,
but I don't know if there is a meeting
room. There's not a common area that's
been established, so I go- I think I
gotta build another common area to be
able to do that, because otherwise
they're not going to be able to actually
train them... Unless they go to the office
to do that, but I don't think that's how
that's done. We need more janitors~! We
need more janit- we have NO janitors! We
need LOTS of janitors, army of janitors~!
Go, my little janitors, go.
Okay, what the hell is this little piece
of shit bu-- "clear indoor area".
Boink! Can you, can you- yeah, thank you! That was in
the way, I appreciate you working so hard
to make this easy on me.
Yeah!
Uh-oh! Uh-oh!
Disorderly! whuh-oh! wuh-oh! wuh-oh! Whoa
Uh-oh, I guess it's okay... maybe? Everyone
was on the way to get food and got all
fubber-nucked. Okay so, we got that done.
We need... Okay, I can finally put in the
one more thing that I need here,
"Workshop pres-" -- Uyup, no not there, not
there, not there, not there,
there we go! Okay, now we need to get people
working on the thing but first I'm gonna
make paving stone here, because it looks
weird withooout it.
Okay, got that. Oh! "Logistics"! There's
"logistics".
Whoo, okay cool, whooo cool. Okay, so I haven't
trained them yet but, we're going to get
there.
*Oooh ahh noises*
Alright, so this is gonna be... Common
room! So Common room in here, boinkiddy boink
we'll get power in there... boinkiddy boink!
just like thusly!
and then, we'll just put a buttload of
chairs inside and everything's gonna be
hunky-dory. Boinkiddy boinkiddy boink,
Okay! So that should be good enough but, now I
need to, alright, "Run training in through
programmer"--ererer
"You will need to assign two hours of
work time the regime schedule screen,
otherwise prisoners will not have time
to attend the training programs." Okay, so
the regime schedule is. right. over...
*turns opera singer*
"regime"! Okay, there we go, so "free" in
"free time".
...No, not "lock up" what, NO not "lock up" uuuh, eeeer
"free time", there
UUUUUH
Ah! Work time! Okay so, work time: 8am. This
will be work time.
Okay, they have free time in the evening
but, for this time they need to do-- Oh,
they only get six hours of sleep a night.
Well, that sucks for them. Oh well.
So we got meeting rooms- I can also, since I got
meeting rooms, I can have the "Carpentry
apprenticeship", "General education,
qualification", "Foundation education
Program", "Behavioral therapy" -
we're going to get all the stuff!
"Pharmacological treatment of jugs" *lol* jugs
"Alcohol groups anonymous", "Parole hearing",
"Spiritual gui-" --  nah, naaah we're not going to
do that. We're not going to do that, either.
We're not gonna do this, either. "All rooms staff only", nuuu.
"No room found", Okay, not that. Okay not that. Alright! But we got these! Good enough!
It's good enough for me and it's good
enough for everybody, so we got that. Auriiight.
We're making progress! It was actually
more of a technical episode but, we're
making a lot of progress. I just want to
see if this works properly, and then
we'll be able to-- heeey! Come on, man! You're
making a bad for everybody around here.
Do I have an infirmary? I don't even
think this place has an infirmary, does it?
God dammit, this prison has just nothin'.
It be nuthin' without me!
Nothin' at all.
Alright what I'm gonna do is, I'm just
gonna make 'this' into also 'that'. it's the infirmary!
Oh geez, all these people need to be
in-firmed! Oh my God!
Eugh! I had no idea it was that dire.
Holy shit. Alright, so just medical beds
is all we really need in there, right?
I suppose I could have fit more; I didn't
know there was that dire.
ok now we need doctors, boink, boink, boink! *Mark noises* Get four of them,
whoa, shoot him up! shoot him up with the
healing juices! Whoa, what is that? Whoa
Well, that's no good. What IS that? There's a Polaroid there.
Whoa, oh, I didn't know that was a secret
that you could find around here! I had no
idea. Ooooh and they're meeting! OOOOh look at them. Ooooh, look at them!!
Okay! So I believe
everything is in place-- there are a lot
of people in the holding cells, why are
there so many of you-- Ooooh, because I
haven't built enough beds for everybody!
Oh my Gawd!
The prison is not big enough for this I
can't handle this!
Oh geez, we can't handle this but either
way-- oh wow a 127 of 51,
that's pretty bad... Oh, we need to start
putting bunk beds in this shit, oh my God!
But either way, that is all the time
have for this episode. I'm going to carry on
in the next episode, on another day so,
thank you everybody so much for watching.
And as always, I will see you in the next
video! Byebye!